après avoir échoué sur une île plutôt
bizarre avec son équipage lara se
retrouve pris dans un nouveau piège elle
va alors réussir à s'en sortir est
remonté à la surface de ligne pas dans
cet abri plutôt chelou au seuil de
survie face à cette île qui a des
secrets plus touche loulou gamme valant
monté un premier feu de camp pour se
réchauffer parce qu'elle a un petit peu
glacé elle va trouver un arc sur un
cadavre bon ça un peu glauque mais au
moins elle peut se défendre et va
pouvoir communiquer avec un ami de son
équipage à l'aide d'un talkie walkie
cave à trouver elle va alors partir à la
recherche de ces derniers loin sait pas
trop encore comment cette recherche va
aboutir et c'est ce que vous allez
découvrir dans ce nouvel épisode
yacht au monde c'est squeeze on se
retrouve aujourd'hui pour le deuxième
épisode tomb raider alors on s'était
quittés en bas de cette échelle je vous
avais fait un bon coup de pub bon
j'avoue alors on y retourne c'est parti
on reprend je vous rappelle qu'on était
à la recherche de nos amis sur l'île
avec lesquels on avait réussi à
communiquer pardon à travers un talkie
walkie qu'on avait trouvé précédemment
ça en fait une longue phrase je sais et
on va rallumer ça voilà c'est parti
enfin pied sur b pour les tentes sûr
qu'on ne va pas d'éteindre le feu est
une arme
hu il ya une fois voir là il ya des gens
apparemment oui
j'espère que cet épisode vous êtes
ministre grenadien là tu es vivante
sam dieu merci surpris
il est avec nous désolé de vous avoir
fait peur
cet endroit le don de rendre les
journées nous venons de contacts et vos
amis
ils sont en route ça c'est le mec qui
s'est fait [ __ ] pas arranger la
famille mon pied mais c'était le mois
que je puisse me voilà maintenant le mec
il essayé de violer un me présente je
m'appelle mathias je suis en seniors
elle a du mal à faire confie je n'ai pas
vraiment été formé pour la survie je le
crains la conférence est oui
sam était en train de me parler de la
reine solaire oui vous pouvez me dire
plus ça m'intrigue
et bien croyez le ou non il y environ
deux mille ans la reine mikko régna sur
pratiquement l'ensemble du jasmin elle
adore raconter cette histoire je passe
mon blog est superbe bouchons par
l'arctique mais aussi un prix table et
autoritaire
la légende dit qu'elle avait des
pouvoirs chamanique
en général vous voyez c'est là que je
décroche chili a pourtant toujours du
fret dans les mines
elle était à la tête d'une armée de
guerrier samouraï les puissants gare de
tempête il commandait aux éléments sur
le champ de bataille dévastant tout sur
leur passage
rennes ordonné au soleil de celui qu'il
a signé sur tout ce qui touche à des
médias depuis les montagnes jusqu'au
mais elle décroche un dollar
laraque rage
sam sam
merde
à
voilà quand il servait les pièges à loup
et c'est pas sûr si tu y as et l'adjoint
pièce est un piège à loup pardon
il est temps du vainqueur jeudi sinon on
n'entendait pas c'est pas trop tard ou
non telle voie de la cua au la poche
comme c'était bien ça donc c'est parce
que je disais dans le premier épisode on
va les humains on est très attention
à bientôt
elle avoue partir et un piège là on
m
mais est ce à moi king mario
ça peut passer une cette juste amendes
sont là les diots longue vie
impossible à retirer
aïe
attention
à la grosse bouffe appel aux consciences
mais avec toute l'équipe ont sapé plus
on est avec vous elle était avec moi
elle était là avec cet homme mathias et
je me suis endormi à mon réveil il avait
dit ce range
vous n'auriez jamais dû partir comme ça
il faut qu'on les retrouve mes os et
pour os
ok on sépare l'inde ne pas rejoindre
hausse avec l'arabe
les autres se disperse pour chercher sap
je vais avec elle
non non non je veux je vais y aller vous
savez vous servir des stars pas très
bien la distorsion ça fait longtemps
mais ça va me retenir trouver ross on se
charge de sa médecin mathias ok donc ils
veulent rassembler tout l'équipage on va
se diviser en deux groupes évidemment
schnorchel avec son pyjama les gens
laissent un peu cassé juste besoin de me
reposer ministre
c'est parce que tu sais ça moche un
polar très bien ne bougez pas je vais je
vais jeter un oeil aux quais
tu veux quoi méchant que lui il va
bientôt mourir j'ai pas j'ai pas passer
pour ce qu'ils peuvent mois que j'ai
passés alors est-ce qu'on a n'ont aucune
compétence
ok on se casse c'est parti alors
on va essayer de retrouver whiteman un
coffre tiens ça ça peut être du bon pour
nous
qu'est-ce qu'il faut vous faire un
piolet plus solides d'accord donc à
plein pour récupérer des matériaux alors
on va prendre le chemin
ça me dit rien qui vaille
[ __ ] il est où ouais mais j'ai plus
envie d'aller là bas chercher des
matériaux mois voilà bah j'ai bien fait
il ya des flèches didon jamais prendre
le chemin que les gens vous conseille ça
nous permet de ramasser quand même dit
flèche c'est pas rien ce pas négligeable
waouh ça fait peur de faire ça mais
alors qu'est ce que c'est que ça rend p
tombeau secret proche âgés bien fait
d'aller ici apparemment relais gens
alors j'ai zappé la séquence je suis
rentré c'est en fait un dlc un tombeau
donc quand on voit un truc ou sur moi
y'a des ressources etc
le truc c'est que alors j'essaie de
faire bonne figure ok cool le truc c'est
que là il nous manque des armes pour
accéder à certains trucs là dedans bref
enfin bref je suis pas censé l'allier
c'est quand même payer et je vais
essayer c'est quand même un dlc et
d'ailleurs je tombe sans faire exprès je
tremble comme ça absolument génial donc
voilà je vous a je vous épargne cette
minute de silence à ne rien faire j'ai
la tête vers le haut ou vers le bas afin
que le masque exprime différentes
émotions alors les éternels projet la
tête vers le haut vers le bas pour
commettre une forte émotion l'aï les
genres jean reno est là et les aaa bat
kent économie puis jallet ceara merde
j'ai l'habitude d'appuyer sur ça pour
quoi
hu matar matar matar matar c'est saab a
rejoint va pas donc eu l' idéologie ou
l'autre il est pas parti l'enfoiré voeux
qui veut ma porte et là c'est bon on les
a eus alors est-ce qu'on peut les
dépasser
ouais c'est parfait voilà donc c'est
plutôt rapide c'est assez agréable
puisque on a là dedans des matériaux ok
il ya un truc là-bas je sais pas ce que
c'est mais écoutez allez on va pas aller
voir c'est bon on verra plus tard
merci monsieur hop on continue c'est
très très souple j'essaie de faire une
couleur correctionnel montage pour vous
voyez quelque chose parce qu'il fait
nuit et la nuit fait plutôt sous main ça
c'est clair et net
justin lavash alors d'un continuer c'est
vers là bas oui les dames
alors est ce qu'il y aurait des
matériaux tout à fait je peux pas
l'ouvrir je mangeais pas le j'ai pas pu
aller qu'il faut ouais alors on va aller
voir un peu plus bas dans celle-ci
matériaux très bien non excusez-moi
saraka exact que là dessus on va aller
mais la torche 1 c'est un fait qu'on
accorde bombe on s'en fout je voudrais
vous pouvez mais la démarche sont
fascinants
je les ai déjà vus
il doit s'agir d'un rituel cette figure
féminine est particulière
on dirait que ça a été fait récemment
oui par les gens de l'île sans doute
alors juger par ces épaves ils ont fait
naufrage
tout comme nous remarque oui reste à
espérer que nous ne finirons pas comme
ça ici et d'actionner l'autre c'est
surtout ça ouais j'ai en vidéo mais
michael il était où ok d'accord ensemble
à tout
on avait perdu mon chat pour la petite
histoire cette piste me servir de
manivelle on va trouver quelque chose
c'est incroyable
ouais bah pas si elles croient pas que
ça alors récupérer des matériaux pour
améliorer le piolet d'accord mais alors
une fois que je les améliorer bah faut
sûrement allez allez ici en fait une
ovation - 6 nov ce faire attendez voir
catégorie est-ce qu'on peut pas
améliorer d'accord bon alors il nous
faut plus de matériaux va sur 50 voilà
donc c'est ça alors on va aller voir
justement là bas les petits trucs que
j'avais dit mot finalement j'aurais
peut-être dû y aller parce que peut
monter ici ouah hausse atteint son pic
au revoir à bientôt
alors on va faire la première partie de
la mcci on ira voir la deuxième tout à
l'heure demain vers l'avant voilà
voilà alors le chez moi je peux la
ramasser mon talent que j'avais mis tout
à l'heure voilà voilà donc j'ai dépassé
salaires hamas mais flash parfait donc
ses deux flèches pour tuer un animal ou
pas bon le championnat est mal la donne
va sûrement des matériaux 30 super
encore un petit effort
alors là bas aussi je crois que c'est
une quête de matériaux au lapin je peux
tuer [ __ ] merde amani leo leo ouais
j'aurais tard chasseurs de ouf enfin si
j'avais roulé ce témoin à l'heure ou à
la vache encore dix et si on n'a pas
l'eau dans les hauteurs enfin ses portes
comme lé waouh c'est glauque et réfléchi
ah pardon tâche est vraiment l'habitude
d'appeler sur ce que c'est stressant
fait qu'on puisse pas courir on peut
vraiment pas courir ce pas possible même
dans les commandes options de jeu
commandes seront tirés visage censure
vite sur internet ifk encore esquivé
sautet caméra
non on peut pas courir bon d'accord
alors encore un et là un truc super
agent pour lui c'est si vous voyez et
que moi je ne vois pas il ya eu d'un
bull annonce est très bien là bas
ou didon [ __ ] c'est bien fait les
bourdes et les cloches par tout ça c'est
qu'il ya un loup non voilà c'est ça
merde retourne à retourner ok ok c'est
un jour noir moderne y aune on met
d'accord non merde merde ça va
complètement merde
bon bah écoutez chers parce que ça
faisait mais apparemment ça te ou une
aide juste à thoune est bon ok alors on
doit tout refaire bon on a retourné
là-bas terme mais ces [ __ ] de nous
ils sont chiants un os en ex pas vrai ça
rend ma maison en fait mon affaire voilà
encore trop fort
parce que moi oui 2e ok on va l'avoir
valoir style et ce qui va pas contents
super bon du coup et qu'est ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire avec toutes ces poubelles
au bout du compte si en a fait tout
autant attaquer comme ça au bout du
compte quand même pas mal de fans elle
s'utilise ouais bah ça devrait suffire
mais moi je vais prendre de l'avant je
vais en prendre d'autres tu vois ça
devrait suffire aux fins et encore là
voilà parfait on a tout ce qu'il faut
trouver un camp et améliorer le piolet
tout à fait alors est ce que là il n'y a
pas quelque chose non plus c'était des
flèches sanctuaire un sanctuaire acquis
partie bien voilà
manatine de la villa de m donc ça c'est
hors de petites histoires bon on va pas
passer dix minutes à chaque fois lire ça
y'a rien à faire dans les sanctuaires
non alors on se casse ya des flèches
encore une quête de matériaux
voilà bah vous bruit comme ça on va
avoir pas mal de davance voilà on a
quand même 30 truc de plus par rapport à
ceux qui se seront arrêtées au sort
quand ils se sont contentés des
traditions j'espère que c'est le bon
chemin puisqu'il n'en sait pas plus
dégage voilà à voir mais sur les loups a
été posté je crois qu'on a d'elle
on a presque je pense toutes les caisses
de matériaux disponibles donc fort
l'améliorer une première fois en tout
cas le violet puis je pense qu'à chaque
fois il en faut un petit peu plus pour
un niveau d'amélioration supplémentaire
c'est un peu logique voir comment
équipements d'accord voilà donc on a
enfin accès piolet un peu pour qu'il
puisse servir de manivelle tac
voilà je la renforcer d'accord on va
vous pourrez les améliorer d'accord puis
je pense qu'il faut débloquer aussi les
ou sa vague un peu par contre quand on
tourne il faut débloquer osciller les
améliorations je sais pas comment un
point de compétence j'ai eu en plus
c'est bien ça allez hop aux compétences
alors cette fois on va le mettre dans
body dont 2 150 et 200 points ça coûte
cher la vache et alors il ya qu un type
de matériau avoir mon compétences
survivants ou chasseurs chasseurs que
136 peu plus de temps pour viser de
meilleurs prix avec votre arc un bon
usage de vos sacs et de vos pages vous
pas transporter plus de munitions une
force a cru bien faire en sorte un mec
son admission on va prendre plus de
munitions plus qu'à des flèches partout
autant en profiter
parfait allez hop on va se servir de
manivelle avec ce truc rigaux ok je suis
prête docteur
c'est parti sur vous voulez c'est le cas
c'est lui c'est lui moi pied plein de
fois ouais ça sert d'eux de manivelle
tout à fait super after ici une forme
d'accord j'ai même pas compris le mec un
peu à l'ouest est une borne à gand ouest
a beaucoup chez vous
alors ils en disent ont pas peur hein
figures féminines sur le portail étant
donnée la sieste il pourrait s'agir de
la reine soleil la reine ni quoi c'est
l'impression d'entendre sam docteur
whitman ça fait donc doute super joli
avec des pouvoirs super super jeu les
deux leur pouvoir j'aime le rock promet
du pouvoir pour qu'elle finisse par
passer pour une sorcière
nous ne résolvons écarter aucune
hypothèse même si cela nous semble
irrationnel
nous avons encore temps de chaque
solution je croirais un temps de mon
père dans sa barbe cette histoire
s'annonce passionnant passionnant
passionnante n'arrive à y survivre
ils sont drôles ils viennent s pas des
bons j'ai en tout cas ils sont habitués
à angers c'est nico
regardez le bal nous voici donc bon
j'aurais dû m'en parle encore vénéré
s'est il devait appartenir au royaume du
siam hatay
vous aviez raison lara royaumes perdus
c'est comme trouvé l'atlantide
sauf que c'est réel docteur whitman
cette île n'est pas un mythe
non mais c'est une véritable mine d'or
connaît vos amis sont blessés
sûrement à cause d'eux reculez pas la
faire confiance que lui wahou vous avez
encore une arme je ne peux pas d'ennuis
nous venons les j'exige ensuite voulu
conduisait à celui qui fait office de
chef baiser vous non je pense que non
débile ce mec ou non ne leur résiste et
badra timing et salaires
et d
un choix mais il est trop bête sont
allés [ __ ]
mon frère et moi qui le fais pas mal
compris pias cazaux a dit la logique
raid à la bobine un choix
bravo
ok alors on se fait attaquer on se fait
violer salm enseignement falloir
affaire butin ok on court très bien mais
thébaux à couvert et en aval
non
contraste récent [ __ ] a commenté
intéressant mais en à merde cours ou
tard à l'arast
hu à la loi presque tous les tuer le
match
je sais tu vois là ok alors je monte par
là j'entends que lui passe on y va 3 2 1
quant à jean royer soit en russie
tap tap
et sont tous morts à la plaine où vous
allez voir qu'on va devoir se passer là
j'étais alors est-ce qu'il va réussir à
retirer sans quoi les vaches mangent
bien fait
après un peu fille de 15 ans
été recrutés down vous feignez les
minières
oh bien
e
ah mais attends mais ils sont marrants
ils préviennent pas enfin ils prennent
un peu trop tard quoi j'en fait
vachement a laissé sa mémé tu as moins
là je tape y mon gars je t'ai bois toile
mais bon tiens
4 défend elle un bond dans les couilles
non à l'écossé
un messi qui ces mecs là bas ça l est
pas trop tâches et les dix noms
m
cette boîte alors est ce pourquoi à mon
dieu
qui perd son art keller a du coup un
pistolet votre démission
super tri et du coup là elle est
vraiment tout seul il ya plus tous ses
alliés on les avait tous mourir où j'ai
des balles
allez pas suivre le chemin on ne peut
pas faire fi nale pas récupéré son arc
si voix la voix mais plus munitions non
plus tu me diras c'est pas très utile là
où on s'en va on va devoir sûrement
faire une attaque de dos puis volé les
munitions comme dans ce long dans les
jeux je vais taille sont tous morts
pourquoi ça j'en ai les questions du par
là bas
je sais pas maman
à nous pardonner
toi par contre comment
tâche du complètement loupé l'enculé
mais pas drôle on peut pas les dépecer
eux
hannibal lecter aussi à nos parcours
sont des matériaux ses coûts sur x
j'appris d'accord combien de balles 16
hockey on voit pas les méga loin aucune
pas un coffre que je vois là bas si
c'est un coffre ouais on a eu des balles
d'accord parfait on continue alors on va
aller là-bas voir ce que j'ai ici
ouais alors enfin faire un univers web
boom
go go go go go servir est allé fonds
waza pour continuer on prends tu quoque
passagers arrière des balles c'est à
dire que ça sent les nuits
tout ce qu'on trouve là
super prenant 7 ème reich utilisez la
pour les élus en silence ok d'accord
cher le port gémir fait je suis à 13
ce que je peux récupérer on y est on
trouve des matériaux sur chaque inhumain
ça c'est bono chez les humains ce que
pendant on sait pas trop à quoi servent
les peaux d'animaux on n'a plus besoin
d'eux
besoin de matériaux choisis
ouais
c'est quoi alors
deux bateaux de recherche bon moi je
fais tout bien merkel j'te casse toi yes
style et sa levier micky mon hockey hier
on a eu plein de trucs qu'on puisse le
récupère nos flèches et ben ça va les
matériaux ils m'ont dit tu vas bientôt
pouvoir améliorer tout ça l'xp aussi
monte qui monte
allez nous aussi on monte on montre la
wii est nul je le vois de la fumée qui
vient des ruines
est-ce que tout va bien
hormis duros ça va mal ici c'est un
véritable massacre
quoi qui sait pas qui sait encore quoi
j'ai été obligé d'en tuer plusieurs je
n'avais pas le choix a dû être difficile
pour toi oh non je m'en bat le goût de
le mignan qu'elle pensait facile grosse
il faut absolument prévenir les autres
ne t'en fais pas pour eux pour l'instant
tu dois trouver un moyen de me rejoindre
voilà
son tombeau ça sent le truc secret ce
pas mais j'ai pas trop envie de m'y
aventurer et de [ __ ] en l'air le truc
alors toi devant ton écran à ton avis
est ce qu on y va ou pas moi je suis
savez quoi
ça a l'air d'être un jeu de façon il
faut tout exploré conciliables
ouais voilà trop un petit truc secret
c'est bien ils ont mis vraiment plein
dans un recoin ont trouvé des trucs
c'est assez impressionnant d'ailleurs il
vous faut du feu une peau douce et ça
alors on repart face aux yachts dufour
ont plané puis ça sert pour le moment à
rien super alors on a gagné le caire
pour voir là où il ya des récompenses
sur la map c'est plutôt cool donc on a
bien fait d'y aller donc ceux qui ont
dit oui je vous fais un gros poutou
droite gauche mais m'améliorer encore
c'est que tout voyage rapide d'accords
comme avait inscrit donc le voyage est
maintenant un autre effective d'un
endroit à l'autre comme ça très très
c'est un cauchemar dont on ne savait pas
je suis vraiment là
je fais vraiment toutes ces choses
le ghana
bien trop cher la fluorine moi je serais
plus du style à jouer alors que ça coûte
cher bruce garance de thurac c'est par
nature plus encore qu'ailleurs
bon j'espère qu'il aura donc c'est alors
on va passer
par là bah ouais c'est ben beau bois
vous avez vu le jeu le jeu et comme très
très doux très très bien fait très mal
au revoir bâtard
mr
non
q l'est il est sérieux lui il s'appelle
super mal aussi
il vendu pas ta gueule
alors next ok il y en a encore où nous
aimons encore là oh non c'est la
racaille classement ouais alger matin où
l'on s'amuse à jouer le matériau ouais
merci band écosse chaud là bas y'a un
truc c'est sûr ah non merde à twilight
d'ailleurs parfait cachés dans les
plantes
voilà on a bien fait d'aller ici alors
vraiment exploré à mort et on trouve pas
mal de choses comme vous pouvez voir les
gens ça c'est ouf j'ai tout qu'est plein
j'ai toutes mes balles de mes flèches
parfait alors autant en arrière parce
qu'elle a un petit peu lent mais on
n'avance pas très vite malheureusement
je me demande combien le solo dur on
verra ça avec le temps vers la boîte
sein des alaouites bascala des way
parfait on en trouve ni vu ni connu ça
ah oui voilà
votre façon ça va faire du bruit alors
autant prend une balle de gamme s'en va
les tuer avec le ballon
sur chaque mot car détruits alors où
êtes-vous bat des cochons je vous
attends bat en battant matin matin y
voit la sagesse aussi
pas mal fidéliser
il craque parfait on va le fouiller par
contre marc passer en mode discret avec
ça
vous êtes quand même vite fait ce sera
par d'autres compagnies
il est complètement courlis donc voiture
et shooter il reste même endroit popopo
je suis bien visible oui
oh on est hué de justesse toi tu vas
dans le feu tranquille
d'autres du tabac n'est pas très bon non
mais attendez jeunesse prenne des
flèches bonne et ben ali et à woippy où
on a fait trop de charges de façon à
quoi bon rester discret qu'on les
reconnaît 7 milliards ici et là voilà on
va servir du g20 sur l'impôt le tac un
truc 500 fut parfait
ok là bas y'a rien
c'est
ah c'est un petit chemin secret mais
quand je vous dis qu'il faut regarder
dans ce jeu c'est hallucinant dans la
plus tendance à aller en haut là par
contre calais ici pourtant on va
sûrement trouver quelque chose non le
feu à sa [ __ ] a pas de feu et si on
monte
avons-nous de gfe je suis l'homme qui
vous recherchez l'oeuf
moi j'aime bien faire les choses non non
rien d'accord bon aller ensemble
s'il y avait un trou ah oui la une a par
contre je te la casse tête elle peut on
en même temps c'est une bôme lycée pas
comme un kangourou peut-être aurions pu
nous éviter de perdre ces quelques
points de vie alors que gatineau où est
ce qu'on va retomber sur un ami ou non
non
j'achète
non juste flèche ça va pas trop
allez courage courage courage
tignes et s'est glissé un peu métier là
parfait
alger par année à 7 ans entre la
quantité
brasse j'arrive
dieu merci du liban
m
mais c'est pas dieu qui m'a sauvé
j'attends de voir
c'est l'impression qu'ils sont acharnés
sur des gens non c'est pas si grave que
ça atk impôts vers mon gars est-ce que
tu as eu des nouvelles des autres
mais qu'est ce que tu fais ils ont pris
mon sac de provisions
l'émetteur du canot était à l'intérieur
si on le récupère pas honda n'a jamais
quitté cette image vous demandez qui au
début j'ai du mal à m'en des
antiseptiques voûte était dans le sac
oui approche approche il est pas mal le
doublage de lara croft à ses puces est
une actrice ans puisqu'il a fait sauvé
la face en suède
non me fais pas ce coup là pas mal hein
ok
il est mort
on
la laisse le groupe saur vaudoise sur
nous pendant qu'il est
hop mai prochain
soit faire
là elle décide de se venger à mon avis
un petit truc qui se passe dans sa tête
genre bon ok arrêtez d'être gentil mais
ça qu'est là où quelque part
aux bâtards j'allais la voir donc je le
sac est là haut mais très très fort
est-ce qu'on peut pas fouiller notre
pote âme en fait il est pas mort ok il
est juste un peu évanoui
comment on va faire un premier pas par
là non ça ça monte
j'irai
ça m'amène tout ça
si ces deux là on vient en fait du roi
oui d'accord merci lucas le molosse
donc jaya plein d'objets si c'est sûr
qu'ils auraient juste bien sa volonté
ferme
voilà un moyen
ce truc là ouais ouais ouais voilà ça je
sens bien
notez dans les deux côtés
c'est pas là pour la période kamakura ça
faisait partie dû à ma taille
et ouais ben aleya matin il est
dangereux
[ __ ]
- c'est qu'on a tiré par le loup et
quand on entre chez ma foi alors est-ce
que je détruis
on peut y aller ah non on va encore vous
montrer par là c'est déjà pouvait aller
c'est là qu'on a eu en face qu'on
escalade ça et qu'on monte là haut
comment on en face
dans ce temps je préfère la veille sur
lienne hadopi n'est pas d'une très
grande utilité
ce qu'on peut monter ici non
allez
pas
ouah ouah [ __ ] non
sort de l'avion bien jouer ta ils ont
également utilisé le même style
angoissant que
ouah
ok on s'en sort ok ok on est ce assez
d'accord
vous êtes tout bon c'est quoi on va
sortir son arme
voilà
lavage la vache c'est pas simple ou la
source
c'est sérieuse la rage me dans un état
de stress récupérer le sac c'est tout
hop s attaquer aux mots de scanner
attention
bon il faut que je rapporte sa hausse
voit pas bien gentiment comme on est
venu à tomber sur des connards de l'eau
maintenant
tiens
t
oui
ça nous fait une jambe n'a pas dépassé
t'as quand même bouffer une jambe au
passage [ __ ] chasseurs de gros gibier
alors comment revenir là-bas par un peu
elle a mal à la jambe ou même panorama
les coûts c'est un peu une guerrière et
dessine je suppose que les laisser ici
alors assez génial j'adore qu'on peut on
puisse trouver un merde éléments
d'escadre qui s'était en fait les
tombeaux fait ça va être un petit peu
relou je pense que après bah en fait
c'est un peu en open world le jeu on se
devra aller retourner au camp on a vu
des tombeaux quand on aura pas
nécessaire pour pouvoir
oh
ok
on a réussi elle vole un petit peu quand
tu trouves voit là bas
dans l'autre
c'est bon
alors comme à pied mais elle sait rien
n'est cassé votre bible ou alors va
continuer tout droit
next allez hop sauve levitt visite
je vais te remettre sur pied
à le mecque et par personne est possible
ou alors c'était un soupir de
soulagement genre il est pas mort
peut-être
enfin
à
c'est pas mal c'est vraiment un guerrier
est ce qu'une jeune fille comme toi
appris à faire j'ai pas mal bossé comme
serveuse de nuit les bagarres ça finit
souvent comme ça bien joué alors il va
falloir l'a porté en haut de la tour
radio c'est ça c'est ça les bailleurs
moyen de diffuser un signal puissant
dans toutes les directions et wayne ma
belle ouais mais c'était un moyen de
donner sa position aussi
écoute
l'arabe
il faut qu'on envoie ce sos
mais je ne suis pas en état de grimper
j'avais peur que tu me dises un truc
comme ça
tu peux le faire la rame après tout
tu es une croft
mais je ne suis pas ce genre de croft
bien sûr que si maintenant on ne sait
pas encore
byers on va améliorer qui a l'air plutôt
bien ou alors celle ci un chai pas
j'espère pour nous que tu as raison
mais soient prudentes là
le gros suspense
crantée alors voilà c'est cool celle-ci
d'accord mais la tester alors
apparemment je pense qu'avec ça on
pourrait accéder au tombeau aussi on
verra père paul je peux y arriver
merde x
le
on est ok mais elle est drôle elle
ensuite
d'accord c'est super cool mon attaquant
fausse décalé au temps pour moi d'accord
très bien c'est clair que ça a l'air de
simplifier un petit peu la chose va pas
se mentir
parfait alors on va passer voir dans le
tombeau vide fait si on peut y aller
comment la ce nouveau piolet parce que
oui du coup pour escale
ça va faire quoi déjà je me souviens
plus à escalader ça que je prenne
l'habitude du coup maintenant on peut
escalader la france en souvenir les gens
je compte sur vous pour me rappeler hop
c'était là le côté pour attendre
attendre ta mok entre 13 caisses
quelques mois allez hop on va aller voir
dans ce foutu tombe au bras du coup il
nous montre un peu au l'été pour ceux
qui l'auraient pas trop voir enfin
savoir ce qu'il ya dans septembre le
maire de sexe c'est parti
qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est ce que la et
bien les gens vous le saurez dans le
prochain épisode
oui je suis une grosse [ __ ] dans ce
groupe on va quand même regarder ce
qu'il ya là dedans
voilà pas je sais par contre c'est très
très sombres c'est très très bien fait
genre là où il n'y a pas le feu ça ne
s'éclate pas vraiment pas quoi c'est
très très bien foutu vous paraître bête
mais
coup ça ne l'est pas aller en font aller
en france on y est presque on est prêt
hop un feu de camp d'accord heureusement
car un sommet avait préparé jean n'a de
leur collection bien jours et donc on a
juste trouvé sept corps doit rien non
ces foires et or et les services de
l'ars enso
gt non j'étais bien censé rester latine
parce que je l ai des sens
ok
et maintenant qu'avons nous donc trouvé
qu'à vous donc trouver absolument rien
c'est servent à rien d'accord bon c'est
juste le fait quand ça c'est pour la
déco très bien à moins que là bas on tue
sial m haies
et celui ci donc à qasr al assi remarque
faut le pousser
vite ouais ok merde non alors si tu
oublies ans monte à avoir sauté dessus
depuis l'annoncé que j'étais
j'entre à de galérer simple trouve donc
tu veux pas monter sur celui-là tu es
fâché
pas de souci non bâti capricieuse mais
alors honte
cordelle mais alors comment on fait pour
monter très vite je pense comme ça
ok bon c'est qu'on va essayer de tomber
je m'en bats les couilles maintenant je
vous dis on se retrouve dans le prochain
épisode bon j'éviterai je pense qu'il
est un petit peu trop lent cet épisode
par exemple la sur la fin on s'est un
peu fait chier donc quoi écouter les
gens on se retrouve là on se retrouve
dans le prochain épisode demain ou après
demain et puis je vous laisse faire vos
petites critiques ou alors dit si vous
avez apprécié lâché un petit j'aime ou
quoi dans les commentaires et à bientôt
au pis